يتعقب خفر السواحل الأمريكي
سفينة تجسس روسية مشتبه بها
تم رصدها في
المياه الدولية قبالة سواحل هاواي، في ظل
التوترات بين واشنطن وموسكو
بشأن الحرب الروسية في أوكرانيا.
مراسل سي إن إن أورين ليبرمان يعيش في
البنتاغون أو في أي مكان آخر  هل
يقول البنتاغون هذا الصباح عن هذه السفينة
القريبة جدًا نظرًا لأنها قبالة ساحل هاواي
كايتلين؟ إن خفر السواحل هو الذي كان
يتتبع هذه السفينة على مدار
الأسابيع العديدة الماضية وكما أشرت فإن
الأمر المثير للاهتمام هنا هو التوقيت
وكل التوتر  بين الولايات المتحدة وروسيا
بين واشنطن وموسكو،
يقول خفر السواحل إنهم يتعقبون
هذه السفينة منذ عدة أسابيع
ويعتقدون أنها
سفينة جمع معلومات استخباراتية روسية،
بلغة واضحة، سفينة تجسس كانت
تتسكع في المياه الدولية قبالة
الساحل.  يراقب خفر السواحل في هاواي
هذا الأمر بمساعدة
وزارة الدفاع. ليس من غير القانوني أو
غير المألوف بأي حال من الأحوال أن تكون
سفن جمع المعلومات الاستخبارية الروسية أو بصراحة
سفن أخرى وطائرات أخرى في
المياه الدولية أو
المجال الجوي الدولي. جمع المعلومات الاستخبارية
يلتقط بشكل أساسي ما يفعلونه.  يمكن أن يكون ذلك في
المياه الدولية، فالتوقيت
هنا هو ما يجعل هذا الأمر مثيرًا للاهتمام
ووفقًا لخفر السواحل، طول
الوقت الذي كانوا يشاهدون فيه هذا
قبالة ساحل هاواي كايتلين،
ومن ثم ما هي المدة التي تعرف فيها ما إذا
كان الأمر شائعًا لشيء ما  مثل هذا
يحدث ولكن هل رأيناه يقترب من هذا الحد
من قبل خاصة في آخر
عام ونصف كما تعلم عندما رأينا
هذه التوترات في أعلى مستوياتها على الإطلاق
بين روسيا والولايات المتحدة
ربما ليس في العام الماضي و  نصف
لكننا رأينا روسيا تتصرف على هذا النحو
في الماضي، على سبيل المثال قبل عامين فقط كانت هناك
سفينة تجسس روسية
قبالة الساحل الشرقي للولايات المتحدة قبالة
فلوريدا، وما جعل تلك السفينة مختلفة هو
تشغيل المياه الدولية مرة أخرى ولكن
وزارة الدفاع اتصلت بها.  يتعلق الأمر بالعمل
بطريقة غير آمنة مما يعني العمل دون
تشغيل الأضواء وعدم الاستجابة
للسفن التجارية، حيث
تصبح هذه الحوادث حوادث وربما يتم
رفعها على المستوى الدبلوماسي.
مثال آخر على الجانب الآخر
قبل بضعة أسابيع فقط رأينا طائرة استطلاع أمريكية
تم اعتراضها من قبل
طائرة صينية في المجال الجوي الدولي مرة أخرى،
وهذا هو المفتاح هنا، وما جعل الأمر مختلفًا
هو أن الولايات المتحدة اتهمت الصين بالتصرف
بطريقة غير آمنة والاقتراب أكثر من اللازم من
الطائرات الأمريكية، وذلك عندما ترتفع هذه
التفاعلات عن التفاعلات البسيطة وتصبح
حوادث يمكن أن تكون لها عواقب و
يتم طرحها على المستويات الدبلوماسية